austria has become the first european
country to mandate coronavirus
vaccinations for all adults it is also
the first country that will now have to
enforce a vaccination mandate starting
next month austrian police will carry
out random spot checks to see whether
people can produce proof of vaccination
those who cannot face fines of 600 euros
or more
this patient is here for his third shot
against covey but taking a jab is no
longer a question of choice starting
today it's compulsory in austria
sad that it needs a mandatory
vaccination because normally everyone
should be wise enough to get the job
automatically
but only a few came for their first shot
the city set up mobile vaccination buses
to increase that number the willingness
to get a job is stagnant despite the new
bill
igbo
i'm against mandatory vaccinations
because i believe this is a violation of
human rights
everyone has the right to freedom
even before the controversial bill was
passed
security was tied at vaccination centers
no other topic polarizes austrians as
much as mandatory vaccinations those who
administer the doses inside can only do
so with security nearby there is concern
about hostile outbursts by anti-vaxxers
tens of thousands of them have been
taken to the streets almost every
weekend across the country to protest
against coveted measures
they are a minority but venerizing who
is researching radicalism says the
protest should not be underestimated
which cannot be allocated to the
organized right-wing crowd or to the
hooligan milieu
these are people from within the middle
class
which has radicalized since the past two
years not only since the mandatory
vaccination and this is very precarious
he says the austrian government failed
to reach this crowd
especially when its declaration last
summer that the covet crisis was over
was followed by a political crisis of
its own
when he created
if you make mistakes with regard to the
management of the pandemic mistakes of
communication and have a government
crisis triggered by corruption then you
face two crises politically
austria expects an avalanche of lawsuits
by those unwilling to pay possible fines
starting at 600 euros and to be enforced
from mid-march
vienna is focusing on those whose
opinion could still be swayed the
undecided
the city put up billboards in various
foreign languages in their latest effort
to counter misinformation
my next guest tonight is arthur kaplan
he's a professor of bioethics at new
york university's grossman school of
medicine he's the author of many books
including vaccine ethics and
policy mr kaplan it's good to see you
again i'm glad you had the time to talk
with us tonight let me start by asking
you about what we're seeing here in
europe we've got a lot of countries in
northern europe who are getting rid of
all of their coveted restrictions and
then we've got austria that has
introduced a vaccine mandate
what do you make of this
well i think europe the u.s north
america are very very tired of covered
they're tired of trying to battle it
they're tired of promises that things
are going to be over soon when they're
not by the way not just due to
government problems but because the
virus has changed
i still favor mandates i still believe
that the right thing to do is to protect
your neighbor
to not clog the hospitals with uh the
sick and the dying from
uh people who are not vaccinated and i
still think vaccination is a key tool
however it's going to be very tough to
collect those fines
in a weird way ethically if the austrian
public doesn't support looking out for
one another and puts individual
self-interest ahead of their neighbors i
don't know that the policy is going to
work
let me
take us a little bit from public health
to public happiness here in the united
states we've got a new gallup poll out
that shows americans continue to
struggle to find the positives in life
and society back in 2020 i think 84
percent said that they were satisfied
with life overall for the second year in
a row now that number is around 67
percent is the pandemic to blame
partly it is you remember
right the pandemic ruined donald trump
it basically cost him the election all
the other issues decide
the lockdowns the damage to the economy
the fights are going back to school
those are real quality of life
impairments
biden has not solved the pandemic either
there have been mixed messages bad
messaging
that leads people to be upset the
economy is suffering in the u.s from
inflation
that leads people to uh be upset
i think another major issue is we are
still struggling in american society
with battles over race they deeply
divide the country it's harsh to say it
but whether it's
attitudes about the police or attitudes
appropriate punishment or who's going to
get into university
we have opened up some wounds in the
society
and they too are taking a toll on the
popularity of this president and
satisfaction with the quality of life
social media
it has fragmented society it's become a
direct delivery channel for
misinformation and we know that this
polarizes society even more
do you think americans are aware of this
and are they aware that this may be
one reason why they feel so bad
about everything around them
well
you know there's not a lot of joy on
social media it's full of griping
complaining
pointing yelling at your neighbor
outbursts if you spend a lot of time
there and many americans do particularly
those who've been shut in for various
reasons
it doesn't boost your morale very much
they haven't figured out what to do
about social media we don't know who's
supposed to edit it we don't know who's
who is supposed to control it we don't
know how to get the uh
hate and the craziness out of it
you know i think the dream was it would
be a wonderful outlet to exchange
information quickly it's turned into a
cesspool that in many ways is driving
down the quality of life not only for
americans but people around the world
you know you say there is a lot of hate
out there and yet
the only category in this poll
where americans say that they see an
improvement
is in the acceptance of gays and
lesbians why do you think that is
well interesting enough that phenomena
shifted before covet
it uh was a movement that if you will
was grassroots particularly younger
people saying we just don't care older
religious leaders may have issues there
may have been entrenched policies about
gays and gay behavior but the younger
generation i think just said it's not
relevant to us we're not paying
attention to old dislikes to old biases
to old prejudices
i'm hoping actually that they can also
lead us forward in matters of race i
think uh you know it's tough to convert
the older generation out of divisive
attitudes but the young may be able to
take us where we ought to go
in terms of similar acceptance of
differences
professor arthur kaplan as always mr
kaplan we appreciate your time and your
valuable insights it's always good to
end on something to feel good about
thank you thank you